these cigarettes kids are using
e-cigarettes but then there are also
people who are using it for smoking
mitigation they're getting off of
regular cigarettes what's your view of
what role they play and the possible
dangers and what exactly is in them
anyway
tobacco still has a lot of people if you
will chronically using it and has
enormous negative health impacts and so
I do think there's value in mitigation
whether it's non combustible cigarettes
or whether it's a cigarette where it
they're really looking at amount of
nicotine that's there I do think there's
value in looking at how to maybe use
less nicotine so things are less
addictive and we're shoulder-to-shoulder
with the FDA and their efforts there I
think the disadvantage is if somehow
that becomes an attractant like julene
or you know I've had my 13 year-old
grandson teach me about this he said
granddad you got to do something about
this you know they're and they're
starting to do dueling all through his
middle school and he's a leader and I
said listen you're not gonna do Julian
then he shows me these little jump tries
he granted that's not a jump drive he
said that's a Julian device and they
make it look like a jump drive because
if you have a Julian device you get in
trouble at school but if you have a jump
drive you know so I think this is where
we have to be careful we don't need the
mitigation strategies to lead to a
introduction of the next generation of
individuals to become chronically
addicted so I think making sure and
doing what we can to make sure
manufacturers are not making these
products to be attractive to minors I
think that's the tension so some people
think well we're not in favor of the
devices for those that we need to
mitigate know we want the mitigation but
we also want to make sure we're not
using these devices as an introduction
of a 12 year old or 13 year old or 16
year old or into a lifetime of nicotine
addiction